welcome back to our Winter Wonderland
the five is tackling some of the
toughest of holiday questions in our
epic Christmas argument Let's Get It On
First up what's better real or fake
trees 65 say they like the plastic ones
we have a word for those people they're
called communists
let's go right in KP right around the
horn real or plastic no but there are
pros and cons to
eat okay so a real tree the pros are
that you can throw it away when it's
done and it smells really good cons are
that it's inconvenient to go get it
especially if you live in a city for a
fake tree it doesn't smell very good you
have to store it but also it's just
available so you don't have to go out
and get it right so I think it just
depends but team Realtree Team Real
trade because Sean as you know eighty
percent of plastic trees are made in
China oh and Mariah Carey saying all I
want for Christmas is you not all I want
for Christmas is G you know what I'm
saying right so as a patriot does this
make you Pro Realtree well I'm a patriot
and I'm not pro-communism Katie I'm not
sure what she is
a poor real tree I go out and I cut my
tree down and put it up listen it's more
work wait a minute
from your property or somebody no
someone else's but it's more work but
clearly like a farm it's an activity for
50 kids yeah you know the kids love it
and it's hard work I mean the the the
fake trees are like fake Christmas it's
like Jesus was real have a real tree
[Laughter]
no prior to marrying your fabulous
husband okay because the city they sell
Christmas trees on sidewalks yeah and
everybody in their single days has
drunkenly brought home a Christmas tree
I have like 10 friends that have done
this yes were you uh in your single days
your Bachelor days uh bring home a
Christmas tree gal
no not on my own but we did we did
Christmas and Hanukkah growing up just
because Christmas is a nice condensed
yeah day where you can have people over
it's always so festive and my parents
were very both Jewish but very Pro like
all the holidays just enjoyed the spirit
capitalists capitalist capitalists not
Communists Patriots
um and we have a small tree this year
that's like up on a Ledge so Cleo can't
live in it or whatever and it's very
cute
yeah it's real and he brought it home I
think he was sober maybe I don't know
brought it home yeah okay uh judge
Realtree fake tree okay I love fake
trees I grew up in Upstate New York so
we always had a a real tree okay I
almost walked off this side but right
now I have a fake tree okay and the
benefit to the fake tree is that it's
always there unless you get compulsive
during the summer and say I'm never
going to put up the tree again you throw
it out then you have to go buy another
one but the thing Katie that you can do
is you can buy those little scents that
plug in the wall and they smell like a
real Christmas tree yeah so the bottom
line is this real trees are the best
fakes are second for sure but I'm into
fakes right now I'm with you okay I like
uh so was I when I dated it was a weird
thing don't even go there next up when
should you open presents first thing in
the morning or should you have to wait
now Katie I'm a right away guy because I
don't think Santa and the elves busted
their butts for you to just go we'll get
to it when we get to it but what do they
do in the past Christmas Eve is for
presents from family and parents
Christmas day is for presents from Santa
and right away that's right so we're
right away in the morning because we
make my kids sit upstairs they can't go
downstairs and see the present so it's
pure torture and then I want to sleep in
and like you know anyway so we do the
morning but you know it's enjoyable kids
call the shots JT
I think for we did first thing until we
were older and my dad would say I have
something in the oven we have to do this
at 2PM and then we did it at two no
first thing is fine with baby Cleo will
you redistribute her presence to other
children uh is practice
yeah no I didn't mean re-gift I meant
like wealth redistribution yeah you're
the best uh Judge first thing in the
morning uh when my kids were little
first thing and if we could have had
them stay upstairs until we told them we
were ready I mean that I never thought
of it but like they come in they wake
you up they want to open their presents
so we're up all Christmas Eve putting
things together laying it out making it
look like Santa came down the tree
eating the cookies when you don't want
to eat the cookies uh but uh for me it's
always midnight I get this I always had
I always I had a lot of front door
Santas too because we put out such good
cookies the year before that some years
Santa didn't fit in the chimney you know
he had like the body by Jimmy Fallon
again like the front door was still open
but like I get it dude I gotta lose
weight too stick with me um
is it okay when you're unwrapping uh do
you clean up as you go
or do you wait till it's over
uh clean up as you go
don't you feel like that's too efficient
though because it's like you're not
enjoying the moment no you do enjoy them
it's easy you gotta save all the bows
too well you have nine kids yeah thanks
you deal for next year you have nine
kids for next year so you have nine kids
do you bring in FEMA as you unwrapy we
get the big black garbage bag so as kids
on wrap presents you put the wrapping
paper in the in the bag because if you
don't do that it's a complete disaster
and you end up throwing away toys with
with the garbage that you have from the
present so I clean up as you go I get it
uh JT do you take your time or are you
just missing the whole point of
Christmas like these people I think Sean
meant a clear bag for recycling and not
a big black trash
uh clean up as you go it's easy when
someone's doing something and you're
still watching but you're just making
sure that you're not sweating in it Mama
cleans up as she goes because no one
else is going to clean up so I'd rather
do it and then enjoy the rest of the day
you just banging out I get it hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else